It's 3 x 10^-9. Let me show why.
At the minimum, both contributions are equal.
I'll explain why that is so in a second.
So we find that the constant, C, x the value h minimum
equals the constant D x ε over h minimum.
>From which follows that h minimum is the square root of Dε over C.
ε is multiplied by a factor of 10^-9,
which means that the value of h min, for double position,
is multiplied by a factor of square root of 10^-9.
Starting from the value of h min for single position,
we have to multiply by the square root of 10^-9.
In total, this is 10^-8.5. And that's about 3 x 10^-9.
An important remark: This model was made for the forward Euler method.
If we have a method of higher order, if we have Ch square, or even Ch 4 in here.
So from this result we learn that as we go from single to double position,
we may be using a step size that's about 4 to 5 orders of magnitude smaller,
and hence the error will be smaller by 4 to 5 orders of magnitude.
The price that we would be paying is that we have
in the order of 10^4 to 10^5 more computation
which looks a little prohibitive, but then again,
with a method of higher order, you need half your steps than with the forward Euler method.
So the affect of roundoff errors tend to be way smaller
with more advanced methods.
In case you're interested, let me explain why these 2 contributions
are equal at the minimum.
Otherwise, skip over the rest of this video.
Substitute the step size h, by e^-u, with an appropriate value of u.
Then the total error becomes C x e^-u + Dεe^u.
Because we are dividing by that power.
Now you can see that the 1st part becomes a falling exponential function,
and the 2nd one becomes an increasing exponential function.
Both fall, and due to symmetry, the minimum has to be where these 2 curves meet.
A completely different approach to that problem is, of course,
to compute the derivative and set it equal to 0.